[Musique]
oh
c'était choquant pour moi j'ai été étonné
à l'époque que chez un bébé simal
n'ayant que des antécédents de médecins pratique
pourquoi elle a ce
vih donc et après avoir appris qu'elle
a le vih
j'ai fait ma routine de pratique  dans une routine
pour
aller au dépistage de tous
ceux qui présentaient les mêmes
symptômes en deux mois, j'avais trouvé 20
[Musique]
cas
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
c'est trop beau pour être vrai et trop
optimiste pour penser que nous  'ai
interrompu la transmission
donc il y a une circulation continue du
virus à larkana
mais la vérité est que notre vitesse de
dépistage a ralenti
[Musique]
vous